évoquons en présence cette affaire
révolte anti elle était avérée un
ouvrier camerounais a déposé plainte
pour violences et discriminations
raciales il affirme photos à l'appui
avoir été ligoté par ses collègues
traités notamment de sales [ __ ]
cet homme et est soutenu par la cfdt la
licra l'entreprise située à moi je serai
même dans le bas rhin se dit très
surprise
alexandra garde la photo est
insoutenable
on se croirait dans la prison d'abou
ghraïb mais cette scène s'est déroulée
dans une entreprise alsacienne théodore
ngamb aux ouvriers de l'usiné osram a
été ligoté et insulté par ses collègues
pour le seul motif qu'ils soient noirs
mais c'est parce qu'ils ont passés dans
leur tête mais j'ai eu trop peur j'ai
vraiment eu trop peur et ce qui est fait
cas après quand ils m'ont mis là dessus
ils sont partis et puisque comme doc est
venu couper les scouts l'agression
remonte à janvier 2003 l'entreprise la
découvre car des photos de la victime
circulent mais ne la prend pas au
sérieux
teodorin combo qui connaît depuis des
difficultés dans son travail et même
rétrogradé sans qu'aucun autre employé
ne soit sanctionné il décide alors de
porter plainte soutenue par la licra et
la cfdt
l'employeur d'appris même là aucune
mesure à l'encontre des tortionnaires
ce qui montre la complicité ou la
tolérance
tout à fait et curieuse de la part de la
direction
alors at elle été aveugle ça se passe
quand même shevell on lui montre la
photo et toujours rien surprise par la
plainte l'entreprise osram une filiale
de siemens qui emploie 1000 personnes et
fabrique des lampes se défend toujours
d'une quelconque attitude raciste entre
ses employés pour eux ils ont fait une
action de est ce que ces troisièmes mi
temps j'en sais rien ils ont ils ont
fait une petite fête je ne sais pas on
va se clarifier ça accusé de violences
volontaires avec préméditation les sept
employés concernés risquent la prison
ferme et l'entreprise est poursuivi pour
discrimination raciale
un espoir pour théodore n combo qui est
toujours
en arrêt maladie